.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Es ist 16 Uhr.
Die Rettungssanitäterin
Rebekka Frieden
ist mit der Rettungscrew der Air
Zermatt unterwegs zur Dufourspitze.
Ein Notruf.
Zwei Bergsteiger
befinden sich zu später Stunde
erschöpft auf dem Gipfelgrat.
Freunde haben den Alarm
der Hütte ausgelöst,
als die Bergsteiger
nicht aufgetaucht sind.
Doch dann - die Überraschung:
Sie hätten am Telefon mehrmals
gesagt, sie wollten keine Hilfe.
Womöglich wegen der Kosten.
- Ihre Entscheidung.
Es ist relativ spät,
um 16 Uhr auf dem Gipfel zu sein.
Das weiss jeder Bergsteiger.
Aber es ist ihre Entscheidung.
Da müssen sie durch.
Mal schauen.
Vielleicht holen wir sie später.
Mir wäre lieber,
wir hätten sie gleich holen können.
So bist du nie sicher,
ob am späteren Abend nicht
doch noch einmal ein Einsatz kommt.
Das ist Teil unseres Jobs.
Ich hoffe einfach, dass sie
kein zu grosses Risiko eingehen.
Die Bergsteiger
wollen tatsächlich keine Hilfe.
Mit einem unguten Gefühl fliegen
die Bergretter zurück auf die Basis.
Dies ist die Geschichte
von Rebekka Frieden,
der ersten Rettungssanitäterin
bei der Air Zermatt.
8 Std. früher am selben Tag
auf der Helibasis.
Schichtbeginn für Rebekka.
Neun Jahre war sie
als Rettungssanitäterin
auf der Ambulanz im Unterland
angestellt.
Vor einem halben Jahr
begann sie in Zermatt
mit der Umschulung
auf den Helikopter.
Es war schon ein Ziel,
hierherzukommen.
Ich denke, das ist sehr gut möglich,
wenn man das will - auch als Frau.
Man muss sich bewusst sein,
dass man als Frau
den gleichen Job machen muss.
Man muss
auch die gleiche Leistung bringen.
Um das stemmen zu können,
muss man trainieren.
Seit drei Monaten fliegt Rebekka
als vollwertiges Crewmitglied
bei den Einsätzen mit.
Sie haben super Wetter gemeldet.
Es wird einiges laufen -
mit Bergsteigern,
mit Mountainbikern, mit Wanderern.
Es sind Sommerferien.
Viele Leute haben frei.
Daher erwarte ich,
dass etwas laufen wird.
Bevor es losgeht, steht für sie
heute Morgen ein Windentraining an.
Morgen!
- Guten Morgen!
Wie geht es?
- Gut. Und dir?
Gut. Tipptopp. Super.
Eine Hauptstruppe
und ein Doppelgehänge nehmen.
Ja, okay.
Dann kommt diese Hauptstruppe
ans Doppelgehänge.
In Zukunft soll sie
auch die Nachtdienste übernehmen.
Dafür benötigt sie
weitere Ausbildungsmodule.
Die Nachtausbildung
ist Anfang August.
Wir gehen mit ihr
in der Nacht fliegen.
Heute schauen wir, wie weit sie ist.
Wie geht es ihr mit der Winde?
Wie funktioniert es
vom Prozedere her?
Ich will das auch mal sehen.
Wenn ich Günther sehe,
der schon seit Jahrzehnten hier ist,
stehe ich
schon noch in den Kinderschuhen.
Für mich ist es eine super Sache,
es so üben zu können,
dass man sich Zeit nimmt,
ein Windentraining zu machen.
Was machen wir?
Zweimal 90 m, oder wie?
90 m?
90 m habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Wir beginnen mit 90 m.
Sonst können wir noch steigern.
* Lachen *
Mit dabei
der erfahrene Pilot Gerold Biner.
Start zur Windenübung.
Auf über 3'000 m ü.M.
muss der Helikopter zwischenlanden,
um unnötiges medizinisches Material
auszuladen.
Auf dieser Höhe
hat jedes Kilogramm zu viel
Auswirkung auf die Leistung
des Helikopters
und somit
auf die Sicherheit der gesamten Crew.
Je höher wir gehen,
desto mehr nimmt die Leistung ab.
Als zweiter Faktor
kommt die Temperatur hinzu.
Jetzt sind wir bei 10 °C
auf 3'200 m ü.M.
Dann nimmt die Leistung des Helis
auch noch einmal ab.
Wir sind schon recht am Limit.
Okay, wir sind ready.
Wir schauen, ob wir starten können.
Jetzt habe ich 80 %.
So sieht alles schon besser aus.
Der Hitzesommer stellt die Bergretter
vor grosse Herausforderungen,
denn jedes Grad mehr bedeutet 10 kg
weniger Nutzlast für den Helikopter.
Ich bin gesichert.
- Gut, ich bin gesichert.
Peter ist angeschnallt.
- Jawohl.
Du sagst,
wenn ich die Tür öffnen kann.
Du kannst die Tür öffnen
und die Winde parat machen.
Die Übung beginnt:
Rebekka bedient die Winde.
Ich schalte um auf "Push-to-Talk".
Jawohl, das ist gut.
Gerold, hörst du mich?
Du mich auch?
- Wunderbar.
Der Arzt
hängt sich am Klettergurt ein.
Rebekka seilt ihn
langsam an der Winde ab,
im Ernstfall zur Unfallstelle.
Wir sind parat.
- Okay.
Du kannst mich runterlassen.
Er ist bei der Kufe.
Er ist unter der Kufe.
Wir gehen 30 m vor.
Präzisionsarbeit
zwischen Rebekka und dem Piloten.
Er sieht die Last unter sich
oft nicht
und muss sich auf die Kommandos
von Rebekka verlassen,
sodass der Arzt im Ernstfall
punktgenau beim Patienten
sicher abgesetzt werden kann.
Dank der Rettungswinde
können so Menschen
aus unzugänglichem,
steilem Gelände gerettet werden.
Vor, zwei.
Vor, fünf.
Doch plötzlich Übungsabbruch.
Einsatz,
höchstwahrscheinlich mit Winde.
Ein Notruf aus der Einsatzzentrale.
Ihr Ziel: das Sommerskigebiet
des Klein Matterhorns.
Rennteams aus der ganzen Welt
bereiten sich hier oben
auf die kommende Saison vor.
Eine junge Skirennfahrerin
des spanschien Nachwuchskaders
ist mit einem anderen Schneesportler
zusammengestossen.
Hoch!
Kopf auf diese Seite.
Hey! Kopf auf diese Seite. Genau.
Das sieht gebrochen aus.
Wir brauchen 10 Min.
Okay, muy bueno.
Jeder Handgriff sitzt.
Rebekkas grosse Erfahrungen
aus den Jahren auf der Ambulanz
sind hier oben unentbehrlich.
4 mg, oder?
Als Erstversorger haben Rebekka
und der Notarzt die Aufgabe,
den Zustand der Patientin
so weit zu stabilisieren,
dass sie transportfähig ist.
Relax!
Okay, nimmst du sie? Das
andere Bein. Genau. An der Hüfte.
Ist es gut für euch?
Eins, zwei, drei.
Relax!
Perfekt.
Sie ist locker.
It's not to heavy?
- No, it's okay.
Die verletzte Spanierin
und ihr Skiteam
sind auf der italienischen Seite
der Matterhornregion untergebracht.
Darum entscheidet sich
das Rettungsteam,
die Patientin nach Aosta zu fliegen.
Ich gehe lieber
via Breithornplateau.
Sie sagten, ich könne direkt gehen.
D.h., ich muss nicht hier,
sondern ich kann gerade hier durch.
Eine weitere Aufgabe von Rebekka
ist es,
während des Fluges dem Piloten
Gerold Biner zu assistieren.
Wo sind wir?
- Wir sind jetzt ...
Wie heisst das?
Oberhalb von Torgnon.
Eine neue Herausforderung
als Rettungssanitäterin
auf dem Helikopter.
In Aosta übernehmen die
italienischen Kollegen die Patientin.
Damit ist der Fall für Rebekka
und ihr Team abgeschlossen.
Rettungssanitäterin bei der Air
Zermatt - für Rebekka ein Traumjob.
Bereits in der Ausbildung
zur Praxisassistentin wurde ihr klar,
dass das Feuer in ihr
für den Rettungsdienst brennt.
In Arosa hatte sie ihren ersten
Kontakt mit der Notfallmedizin.
In Arosa habe ich
in einer Hausarztpraxis gearbeitet.
Dort kam ich mit
den ersten Skiunfällen in Kontakt.
Es kristallisierte sich heraus,
dass ich noch etwas machen wollte.
Die Notfallmedizin
hat mich immer sehr interessiert.
So führte eins zum anderen.
Dass ich jetzt die Chance habe,
das bei Air Zermatt zu machen,
ist megacool.
Ich habe in den letzten Jahren
auch viel investiert.
Ich denke, das ist
so ein bisschen der Lohn dafür.
Rebekka hat ihrem Ziel
vieles untergeordnet.
So hat sie als einzige Frau
der Schweiz den internationalen
Master of Mountain Emergency Medicine
abgeschlossen.
Ich sehne mich immer
nach dem nächsten Einsatz.
Ich bin neu hier und möchte
möglichst viel Erfahrung sammeln
und möglichst viel erleben.
Anderseits bin aber auch froh,
wenn ich mal Zeit zum Lesen habe
oder um E-Mails zu beantworten.
Es hat zwei Seiten.
Der Tag neigt sich dem Ende zu.
Von den erschöpften Bergsteigern
an der Dufourspitze
haben sie bisher nichts mehr gehört.
Mit einem unguten Gefühl
haben sie den ersten Rettungsversuch
abgebrochen.
Und dann um 20 Uhr:
Notruf von der Dufourspitze.
Das, was sie geahnt haben, tritt ein.
Die beiden Bergsteiger sind in Not.
Jetzt haben sich die zwei von der
Dufourspitze nochmals gemeldet.
Sie wollen
jetzt doch abgeholt werden.
Jetzt holen wir sie.
Mal schauen,
ob danach Feierabend ist.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Sie wissen nicht, was sie erwartet.
Mit an Bord
ist ein Gebirgsspezialist.
Der Bergführer
unterstützt das Team bei der Rettung.
Oh! Super!
Jetzt hat es auch noch Nebel.
Bravo, sie sind im Nebel!
Ja, am Nachmittag
wäre es besser gewesen.
Das macht das Ganze
relativ schwierig. Wir schauen mal.
Die Bergsteiger sind
mittlerweile seit 17 Std. unterwegs.
Erschöpft und blockiert
sitzen sie auf dem Gipfelgrat.
Seit dem ersten Notruf vor 4 Std.
sind die beiden nur noch
wenige hundert Meter vorangekommen.
Der Süden ist frei.
- Okay.
Gut, wir gehen mit der Winde runter.
Thomi macht sich parat.
Okay.
Die Dufourspitze,
der höchste Punkt der Schweiz.
Es ist ein Einsatz am Limit.
Ich bin gesichert.
Ich öffne die Tür.
Auf 4'500 m ü.M. ist der Helikopter
an der absoluten Leistungsgrenze.
Jeder Handgriff der Crew muss sitzen.
Warte!
Dazu kommen Nebel
und starke Windböen.
Voll am Anschlag. Wartet noch!
Noch 15 m.
Der erste Rettungsversuch
muss abgebrochen werden.
Beim zweiten Mal klappt es.
Sie erwischen ein Nebelloch.
Winde frei! Ich sehe ihn nicht.
Wie viele Meter hatten wir?
- Wir hatten 65 m.
Okay.
Das war tipptopp, Rebekka!
* Pompöse Musik *
65 m weiter unten
werden die Bergsteiger
an die rettende Leine gehängt.
* Pompöse Musik *
Der Bergsteiger und die Bergsteigerin
stammen beide aus Polen.
Sie sind erschöpft und entkräftet
und hatten Glück,
dass sie doch noch
gerettet werden konnten.
Nun müssen sie für die beiden
Rettungsaktionen aufkommen.
Ob ihre Versicherung das übernimmt,
ist unklar.
Deshalb werden auf der Basis
ihre Personalien und
Kreditkartendaten aufgenommen,
in der Hoffnung, dass sie
diese Aktion selber bezahlen können.
Nur zu oft blieb die Air Zermatt
in ähnlichen Fällen
auf den Kosten sitzen.
Micha, der heute Nacht Pikett hat,
hat sich bereit erklärt,
die beiden anzuschauen,
damit wir den Heli
wieder parat machen können.
Er nimmt auch die Personalien auf.
Einer der beiden wurde höhenkrank,
mit Kopfschmerzen, Übelkeit usw.
Deshalb hatten sie länger.
Hier auf "normaler" Höhe
geht es ihnen wieder besser.
Für die Nacht suchen sie sich nun
eine Lösung im Dorf.
Du kannst es mir hinlegen.
Ich mache es morgen.
Gut. Ich werde es noch einscannen.
Bitte?
- Ich scanne es noch.
Du kannst es mir ins Fach legen.
Eine spezielle Aktion für Rebekka.
Das war
mein bisher höchster Windeneinsatz.
Es war nicht einfach, weil wir doch
an die Belastungsgrenze kamen,
auch vom Helikopter.
Es ist cool,
dass es so gut geklappt hat.
Wir sind froh, dass wir
alle gut retour gekommen sind.
* Sanfte Musik *
Heute hat Rebekka frei.
8 Uhr im Fitnesscenter.
Salü!
Man hätte zählen müssen.
Seit sie
als Rettungssanitäterin arbeitet,
geht sie ein- bis zweimal
in der Woche ins Krafttraining.
Nicht ganz freiwillig.
Sie ist in einer Männerwelt,
in der Kraft gefragt ist.
Und sechs. Schön!
Deshalb muss sie gerade hier
mehr investieren als ihre Kollegen,
um ihren Traum zu leben.
Eigentlich ist es genau das,
was ich im Job brauche.
Du hilfst tragen und stehst so auf.
Du arbeitest
v.a. aus den Beinen heraus.
Deshalb ist es
eine wichtige Übung für mich.
Versuche,
noch etwas näher zu stehen!
Ein bisschen näher ...
- Genau.
Geradeaus schauen!
Schön!
Zwei und ...
Zwei ...
Wenn ich mir etwas vornehme,
gebe ich alles, um es umzusetzen.
Wenn es nicht klappt,
kann ich sagen,
dass ich
zumindest alles versucht habe.
Bis jetzt ...
... hat erstaunlich viel geklappt.
See you next week.
- Ja.
Seit zwei Monaten
lebt Rebekka auch in Zermatt.
Sie hat ihr vertrautes Leben
im Unterland zurückgelassen
und ist
in eine einfache Wohnung gezogen.
Es ist
eine kleine 1,5-Zimmer-Wohnung.
Aber das reicht tipptopp.
Mehr brauche ich nicht.
Wenn das Wetter schön ist
und ich frei habe,
bin ich sowieso unterwegs.
Sonst bin ich am Arbeiten.
Einmal im Monat
bin ich im Unterland.
Meine Kollegen und die Familie
sind unten.
Auch im Bündnerland.
Die Schweiz ist so klein.
Bis ins Bündnerland
bin ich schon 4,5 Std. unterwegs,
aber es ist machbar.
Die Tickets haben wir.
Deshalb kommen ihre Freunde
oder Freundinnen nun zu ihr.
So auch Julia, eine Freundin
aus den guten, alten Arosa-Zeiten.
Ihr heutiges Ziel: eine kleine
Klettertour am Riffelhorn.
Hübsch!
- Gell?
Richtig cool.
- Megaschön.
Ich merke, dass ich
auf Weisshornhöhe in Arosa wäre.
Plus/minus.
Man atmet noch etwas mehr.
Uns verbindet
auch die Liebe zu den Bergen.
Sie ist auch ein verrücktes Huhn.
Als ich nach Arosa kam,
war Rebekka
die erste coole Bergfrau,
die mich bestärkt hat
bzw. die mir gezeigt hat,
was man als Frau alles machen kann.
Ich werde ganz rot.
Das wurde mir bewusst.
Du bist eigentlich die Erste,
von der ich dachte: "Doch, cool."
Es freut mich sehr, dass sie
ihren Traum verwirklichen konnte
und nach all ihren Ausbildungen
nun dort ist, wo sie hinwollte.
Gut?
- Passt.
Tipptopp!
Du kannst starten.
Bis nachher.
- Bis gleich.
Ja, diese Platte.
All die teils tragischen Unfälle,
die Rebekka bei ihrer Arbeit erlebt,
hinterlassen auch bei ihr Spuren.
Julia, du kannst kommen.
Ich glaube schon,
dass man noch vorsichtiger wird,
wenn man sieht, was alles
schiefgehen kann in den Bergen.
Wir kommen meistens,
wenn etwas passiert ist.
Es gibt diese Portion Schicksal.
Das können wir nicht ändern.
Hier oben kann sie die Arbeit
vergessen und neue Kraft tanken.
Wenn man unterwegs ist,
weit weg vom Geschehen,
strahlen die Berge halt schon
eine unglaubliche Ruhe aus.
Es ist ein bisschen beides:
Rückzugsort
und Ort, um Kraft zu tanken.
Natürlich
ist es auch ein Abenteuerort.
Man erlebt etwas und kann
die eigenen Grenzen ausloten.
Im Job
bin ich so oft unter Menschen.
Ich geniesse es,
einfach mal für mich zu sein
oder so einen fantastischen Ausblick
zu geniessen.
Bitte schön!
- Merci!
* Ruhige Musik *
Am nächsten Morgen:
Rebekka ist zurück auf der Basis.
Der Tag beginnt für sie mit einem
Notruf aus dem Gebiet der Monte Rosa.
Spalteneinsatz.
Gebirgsspezialisten steigen dazu.
Kabine gut.
- Okay.
Wieder mit dabei: Pilot Gerold Biner.
Wir wissen,
dass es einen Spalteneinsatz
in Höhe Schwarztor gibt.
Mehr Informationen
haben wir noch nicht.
Das kam sehr kurzfristig rein.
Wir wollten eigentlich
auf eine andere Mission.
Dann hiess es: "Stand by!"
Ich muss mal schauen.
Ein Spalteneinsatz
ist nichts Ungewöhnliches
in diesem heissen Sommer.
Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui!
Hast du gesehen?
3 m zurück bis zum roten Seil.
Ein Bergsteiger ist 10 m tief
in eine Spalte gestürzt.
Nun steckt er fest.
Sein Seilpartner
konnte den Sturz stoppen.
Ich öffne die Tür.
- Yes.
Das Gelände ist zu steil zum Landen.
Schwebend steigen
die Rettungsspezialisten aus
und beginnen mit der Bergung.
Noch ist nicht klar,
wie es dem Verunfallten geht.
Gerold und Rebekka fliegen derweil
zu einem nahe gelegenen Platz,
wo sie landen können.
Wir warten hier,
bis sie ihn draussen haben,
bzw. bis wir
mehr Informationen haben.
Dann wissen wir auch,
wie es dem Patienten geht.
Primär geht es jetzt aber darum,
ihn aus der Spalte zu holen.
Es ist eine ziemlich grosse Spalte.
Es sind
bereits mehrere Leute vor Ort.
Es ist relativ warm.
Hier oben hat es 8 °C.
Und dann ein Funk vom Gletscher.
Ja, Thomi?
Der Patient ist draussen,
unverletzt.
Aber wir nehmen ihn trotzdem mit.
Du kannst die Patienten
in zwei bis drei Minuten holen.
Okey-dokey.
Die Holländer hatten grosses Glück.
Sie sind beide tatsächlich unverletzt
und können selbstständig
in den Helikopter einsteigen.
Russisches Roulette -
so bezeichnen die Retter die aktuelle
Situation auf den Gletschern.
Der schneearme letzte Winter
und die Hitzeperiode
haben dazu geführt,
dass viele Schneebrücken unter
der Last der Bergsteiger einbrechen.
Es gab zwei Spuren.
Die eine ging über die breite Spalte
und die andere links vorbei.
Ich sagte noch zu Mark:
"Sollen wir links gehen?"
Und da war er schon im freien Fall.
Glücklicherweise konnte ich
dank meinen Steigeisen bremsen -
5 m bevor ich selbst
reingefallen wäre.
Das war
ein ziemlich beängstigender Moment.
Aber jetzt sind wir hier.
Dank den Rettern.
Nachdem das erste Adrenalin
aus dem Körper war,
habe ich mich umgeschaut
und gedacht:
"Das ist ziemlich furchteinflössend,
ziemlich tief."
Da beginnst du zu denken,
was alles passieren könnte.
Das macht einem schon Angst.
Ich würde lügen,
wenn ich sagen würde,
dass ich nicht Angst gehabt hätte.
Wir hatten Glück.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich mich schämen soll.
Nein, du warst super!
Wir werden
wieder in die Berge gehen.
Ja, sicher!
Oft können solche Unfälle
auch tragisch enden
und die abgestürzten Bergsteiger
können nur noch tot geborgen werden.
Es ist Teil
des Berufsalltags der Bergretter,
mit dem sie umgehen müssen.
In Gesprächen probieren sie,
solche Situationen aufzuarbeiten.
Es ist nie schön, für eine
Leichenbergung gerufen zu werden.
Aber es ist Teil unseres Jobs,
auch das zu machen.
Du musst ein bisschen
ein Meister im Vergessen sein.
Ja.
Während des Einsatzes
ist das kein Problem.
Da ist man sehr fokussiert auf
die Kommunikation mit dem Piloten.
Man denkt nicht daran. Das kommt
erst nach dem Einsatz hoch.
Wenn es schlimm ist,
macht man ein Debriefing
und spricht
mit dem Arzt oder mit dem Piloten.
Das hilft viel.
Oder zu Hause mit der Familie.
Letztendlich ist es auch
der letzte Dienst am Menschen.
Es ist unsere ehrenvolle Aufgabe,
ihn vom Berg zu holen,
damit er bestattet werden kann.
Wenn man diese Aufgabe annimmt,
ist es halt auch so ...
... dass du einen Weg finden musst.
Einfach ist es nicht.
Rund 130 Personen verunfallen
jedes Jahr in den Bergen tödlich.
Ein Drittel davon muss
von der Air Zermatt geborgen werden.
Magst du mir eine Hand reichen?
Alltag auch für Rebekka,
die bei ihrer Arbeit
von lauter Männern umgeben ist.
Hält das?
- Nein.
Hältst du es und ich fahre?
Oder wir tragen es so rüber.
Das ist die andere Möglichkeit.
Komm, wir machen es unten drunter!
- Hat es noch Platz?
Halte den Tragetisch!
- Ja.
So, jetzt sieht es besser aus.
Neben einer Pilotin und einer Ärztin
ist sie die einzige Frau
im Rettungsteam der Air Zermatt.
Kommt der Wagen
zurück in den Hangar?
Ja, gerne.
Ich mache hier meinen Job.
Den versuche ich
möglichst gut zu machen.
Ich denke,
die Akzeptanz des Teams ist da.
Ich finde nicht, dass es speziell
ist, weil ich eine Frau bin.
Pass auf!
Ich arbeite
sehr gerne mit Männern.
Ich denke, es spielt keine Rolle,
ob ein Mann oder eine Frau kommt.
Schlussendlich
muss der Job gut gemacht werden.
Ich muss in der Lange sein,
Patienten einladen zu können.
Dafür trainiere ich regelmässig.
Ich glaube,
dem Patienten spielt es keine Rolle.
Es gibt immer wieder mal Sprüche.
Das darfst du dir
nicht zu nahe gehen lassen.
Ich höre gar nicht gross hin,
wenn es Sprüche
unter der Gürtellinie sind.
Nehmen wir noch die zwei Rucksäcke?
Die zwei Rucksäcke
und den Sauerstoff, oder?
Ja.
Es ist 18.30 Uhr.
Noch einmal
ein Spalteneinsatz zu später Stunde.
Die Meldung: Eine Bergsteigerin
wird am Riedgletscher
in der Mischabelgruppe vermisst.
Sie hat sich
von ihrem Kletterpartner getrennt.
Im Tal
steigt Gebirgsspezialist Rütschi zu.
Als Bergführer
kennt er die aktuellen Verhältnisse
auf dem Gletscher bestens.
Rütschi, erzähl mal!
Du weisst nicht mehr als ich.
Vom Stecknadelhorn aufs Windjoch.
Sie haben sich um 13 Uhr getrennt.
Er hatte ein Problem
mit den Steigeisen.
Er entschied,
Richtung Mischabel abzusteigen.
Er ist in Saas Fee angekommen.
Sie sagte, sie hole das Material
in der Bortierhütte.
Vom Windjoch.
Von ihr hört man nichts.
Ich kann mir ungefähr vorstellen,
wo sie ist.
Du kannst ja mal oben beginnen.
Oder was meinst du?
Du weisst sicher wo.
Beim Ulrichshorn.
Aber ich weiss auch nicht genau.
Dort oben links,
bei diesem Übergang,
habe ich auch schon Leute
aus einer Spalte geholt.
Die Suche nach
der vermissten Berggängerin beginnt.
Hier ziehst du nach rechts. Genau.
An der Felswand rechts,
wo es viele Löcher hat.
Hier ist sicher ein heikler Punkt.
Gleich rechts von uns.
Uh!
Wenn die da allein runter ist ...
Da kann man schon ausrutschen.
- Oh!
Das ist verdammt schwierig.
Geh etwas näher ran
an die Hauptlöcher.
Ich schlage vor,
dass wir hier gerade hochgehen.
Bis zum Windjoch.
Hier siehst du das Ulrichshorn.
Ja, genau.
Wenn sie über das Ulrichshorn geht,
steigt sie links
den steilen Grat hinunter.
Hier oben
kann sie nicht in ein Loch fallen.
Wer weiss, was die gemacht hat.
Und dann: Spuren im Gipfelbereich.
Ist diese Wechte frisch?
Das sieht sehr frisch aus.
Aber das macht null Sinn,
dass die hier rausgeht.
Wenn hier nichts ist, gehen wir
mal über den ganzen Grat.
Hier durch.
Ich wäre hier rübergegangen,
weil ich Angst gehabt hätte,
über den Gletscher zu gehen.
Das ist relativ einfaches Gelände.
Doch keine Spur
von der Bergsteigerin.
Dann plötzlich ein Funkspruch
aus der Bordierhütte:
Eine Person
ist soeben bei ihnen eingetroffen.
(Funkspruch) Sie ist eben
hier auf der Hütte eingetroffen.
Okay, tipptopp.
Was sagt er?
Sie sei
eben in der Hütte eingetroffen.
Das wäre schön.
Aber das sind schon
verdammte Trottel.
Michi, wo habt ihr sie gesehen?
(Funkspruch)
Auf der Hütte neben mir.
Kannst du sie gleich fragen, ob
sie sich vom Begleiter getrennt hat?
(Funkspruch)
Es ist die gesuchte Person.
Wie kann man sich
auf so einem Gletscher trennen?
Unverständlich.
Die haben keine Ahnung,
was passieren kann.
Ist ja gut gegangen zum Glück.
Die Meldung aus der Hütte ist,
dass die vermisste Person
einen verwirrten
und erschöpften Eindruck macht.
Das Rettungsteam entscheidet sich,
im Tal zu landen
und auf sie zu warten.
Der zweite Suchhelikopter
fliegt die vermisste Person
zum Zwischenlandeplatz.
Rebekka nimmt sie in Empfang.
Hallo!
Es ist eine Schweizerin
aus der Romandie.
Okay. Langsam!
Okay.
- Noch einmal?
Nein, wir schauen erst einmal,
was los ist.
Sprichst du deutsch?
Ein bisschen, ja. Hochdeutsch.
Bist du runter...
Ich bin in eine Gletscherspalte
gefallen. 20 m tief.
Ich hatte keinen Empfang,
um die Rega anzurufen.
Ich habe es viermal versucht,
aber ich hatte keinen Empfang.
Ja.
Danach habe ich es
mit den Eisschrauben versucht.
Ich schaffte es,
aus der Spalte zu klettern.
Okay.
Hast du irgendwo Schmerzen?
- Ich habe Schmerzen am Ellenbogen.
Kannst du ihn bewegen?
Ich denke, es ist bloss der Schock.
Hast du hier Schmerzen?
- Nein.
Was denkst du?
Es stellt sich die Frage,
ob wir dich röntgen lassen sollen,
dich ins Spital bringen sollen.
Nicht? Okay.
Nein, in zwei Tagen
ist es wieder gut.
Ihr wart lange unterwegs.
Wann seid ihr gestartet?
Ich habe den Nadelgrat gemacht.
Und der Kollege ging nach Saas Fee?
Ja, er hat ein Steigeisen verloren.
Dann bist du über das Ulrichshorn
und dann den Grat hinunter.
Ja, in der Fläche
nach dem Ulrichshorn.
Okay.
Zum Glück bist du rausgekommen.
Bist du
in eine Gletscherspalte gefallen?
Ja.
- Wie viele Meter?
20 m - denke ich in etwa.
- Nein!
Es dauerte lange,
bis ich draussen war.
20 m?
Aber es ist wirklich, wie man sagt:
Der Überlebenswille,
der mich gerettet hat.
Die Kraft der Verzweiflung.
Warum filmt ihr?
Ich habe ja seit zwei Tagen
nicht mehr geduscht.
Der Gebirgsspezialist Rütschi
bringt die Bergsteigerin
für die kommende Nacht
in ein nahe gelegenes Hotel.
Ihr geht es so weit gut.
Sie ist nervlich und körperlich
völlig am Ende.
Ich möchte nicht, dass sie
ins Auto sitzt und davonfährt.
Deshalb ist der Plan,
sie in ein Hotel zu bringen,
damit sie mal duschen kann.
Du wirst immer schmaler.
Sprichst du deutsch?
- Hochdeutsch oder französisch.
Sie ist 20 m in die Spalte gefallen.
- Achtung, Natel!
Er kümmert sich um dich.
Irgendwo
kriegen wir dich schon unter.
Er ist kein Böser.
- So sieht er nicht aus.
Super! Alles Gute!
Ciao! Macht ihr auch Feierabend?
- Mal schauen. Sag es nicht zu laut!
Nicht zu laut sagen.
Gehen wir nach Hause?
- Ja.
Es war Rebekkas Traum,
einmal als Rettungssanitäterin
bei der Air Zermatt zu arbeiten.
Ein Traum, den sie sich
hart erarbeitet und verwirklicht hat.
Wenn ich auf die letzten fünf Jahre
zurückblicke und sehe,
welche Türen sich geöffnet haben,
muss ich sagen, dass ich das nie
erwartet, bzw. nicht erhofft hätte.
Jetzt ist es so weit. Mal schauen,
was die nächsten Jahre bringen.
Man muss Träume haben.
Einige kann man erfüllen,
andere bleiben Träume.
Ich möchte am Morgen aufstehen
können und mich auf den Job freuen
und nicht mit einem Anschiss
aus dem Haus gehen.
Und dies mit dem Ziel,
auch in Zukunft möglichst vielen
Menschen in Not helfen zu können.